mit 37 zurück ins Haus der Eltern ziehen
getrennt von der Frau seiner Träume er
habe sich im Leben noch nie so
beschissen gefühlt erzählt will Hill
seit er aus Dänemark abgeschoben wurde
weil er Brite ist und der brexit sein
hässliches Gesicht gezeigt habe
ich habe schon in einigen Ländern gelebt
und mich nie nicht willkommen gefühlt
dass das System mich nicht dort haben
will als jemand der Steuern zahlt zwei
Jobs hat und in Dänemark nicht einen Tag
arbeitslos rumgehangen hat
in zwei Wochen will er eigentlich Ida
heiraten 2017 in Rom verliebt landen die
beiden nach einigen hin und her in
Kopenhagen die das Heimat will Experte
für cybersicherheit baut sich in drei
Jahren ein Leben auf viel Arbeit wieder
erleidet eine Fehlgeburt und will
verpasst die Deadline eine
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung zu beantragen
es folgen neun Monate Rechtsstreit
Unsicherheit und es gipfelt vor Wochen
in der Aufforderung das Land zu
verlassen
du verlierst dein Leben lässt deine
Familie und Freunde zurück aber für
meine Freundin ist es noch härter die
nun allein in unserer gemeinsamen
Wohnung sitzt dort jeden Morgen allein
aufwacht und wir nicht wissen wie es
weitergeht immer wieder taucht eine neue
Hürde auf die wir überwinden müssen
leben und arbeiten überall in der EU
dafür stand auch der britische pass mal
in Dänemark steht er nun für rund 300
Briten und ihre Familien die schon
abgeschoben wurden oder dazu
aufgefordert so wie viel Russel auch er
voll integrierter Job Familie beantragt
sein Bleiberecht vier Tage zu spät
erklärt gegen seine Ausweisung die
Behörden hätten ab 2020 eingewanderte
Briten unzureichend informiert sein
Alltag in Dänemark läuft erstmal weiter
dennoch will ich wissen
your life hat der brexit sein Leben
ruiniert
es hat mein Leben ganz sicher ruiniert
und der Staat verliert Einnahmen weil
wir nicht weiter Steuern zahlen und die
Abschiebung zusätzlich kostet dazu wird
es den dänischen Steuerzahler Millionen
von kronenkosten wenn diese Irrsinn vor
Gericht jahrelang durch alle Instanzen
geht
es gibt nur Verlierer bei einer Sache
die der einwanderungsminister in einer
halben Stunde aus der Welt schaffen
könnte
der brexit produziert menschliche Dramen
im kleinen und wirtschaftliche im großen
ein schier unglaublicher Akt von
ökonomischer selbst Sabotage erklärt
Danny lawren Geschäftsführerin eines
mittelständischen chemikalien-händlers
vor dem brexit haben sie Zutaten aus
aller Welt für Shampoos Krebs oder Deus
von Südengland in die EU geliefert über
Nacht will dieses Geschäft Weg der groß
Kampagne nicht mehr Teil des
reach-systems ist einer Datenbank für
geprüfte und zugelassene Chemikalien
allein das neue Zulassungssystem was nur
für Großbritannien gilt kostet uns viel
Geld und der britischen Industrie
Milliarden es führt dazu dass wir
weniger Chemikalien aus Europa
importieren können was bedeutet das
Firmen auf der Insel weniger herstellen
am Ende entsteht so ein enormer Schaden
für unsere Wirtschaft
im Warenhaus in Hells Bree mussten 13
von 40 Mitarbeitern gehen weil das
eu-geschäft nun in Polen abgewickelt
wird mit Gefahrgut kennen Sie sich aus
aber wie ätzend der brexit für
Britannien ist überrascht die Bilanz
nach zwei Jahren es trifft die
inselwirtschaft hart 15% weniger ein-
und Ausfuhren in die EU durch den brexit
rechnen unabhängige Experten mit bis zu
6% weniger Wachstum des
Bruttosozialprodukts hunderte Milliarden
die nicht mehr erwirtschaftet werden die
Regierung redet sehr viel darüber dass
die Pandemie und Ukraine Krie folgen die
Gründe dafür sein natürlich spielen
dieser eine große Rolle aber in unserer
Branche kann man den Unterschied sehr
klar erkennen zwischen den Folgen von
kovit und Ukrainer beides punktuelle
sorgen und dem brexit der schwächt uns
schon eine Weile und das wird
langfristig so bleiben eine nicht enden
wollende Belastung für Großbritannien
[Musik]
kommt in Mode alte Videos der Pro
austrittskampagne werden aus Häme von
brexit Gegnern wieder tausendfach
geteilt etwa die Verheißung vom
gesundheitsparadies wenn man die EU
verlassen hat wenn du die ganzen EU
Einwanderer nicht mehr alles verstopfen
die Realität 10000 Ärzte oder Pflege aus
der EU fehlen dem staatlichen
Gesundheitssystem NHL SS völlig
überarbeitetes Personal dazu die
Pandemie folgen und kein Geld für große
Lohnsteigerungen der Mix aus dem Streiks
gemacht sind seit Dezember tageweise
Ausstände was die Probleme weiter
verschlimmert 7 Millionen Briten warten
auf notwendige Behandlungen nach einem
Herzinfarkt eine Stunde und mehr auf den
Rettungswagen warten ist im ländlichen
Raum mittlerweile die Regel fast
wöchentlich neue horror-statistiken
nicht alles ist brexit aber der brexit
Macht in Sachen Wirtschaftskrise alles
schlimmer 55% der Briten so viele wie
nie halten den Austritt mittlerweile für
einen Fehler darunter jeder Fünfte der
dafür gestimmt hatte
die Wirtschaftskrise beginnt wehzutun in
guten Zeiten fällt es leicht sich nicht
beeindrucken zu lassen wenn es heißt der
brexit ist schlecht für die Wirtschaft
aber wenn man nicht mehr heizen oder
seine Kinder ernähren kann sieht das
anders aus
wie es weitergeht das Königreich werde
sich durchwursteln müssen ergänzt
Professor Männern was den brexit
betrifft gebe es politisch erstmal
keinen Weg zurück will hillhoff dass es
mit seiner Hochzeit in Kopenhagen doch
noch irgendwie klappt und er in zwei
Wochen ja zu jeder sagen darf
es ist keine große Hochzeit geplant aber
ein paar Gäste haben ihren Flug schon
gebucht und ich würde es Ungarn
verschieben im Moment würde ich sagen
steht es 50 zu 50
um seine Zukunft in Dänemark in der EU
was seine Situation
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung zu spät beantragt
und der brexit gemeinsam haben scherzt
er bei ziemlich dumm und verdammt
traurig